Imagine you were out in public and you found
yourself injured.
Maybe you were in an accident and couldn’t
move, or someone had mugged you in the ensuing
scuffle you’d ended up getting hurt.
Laying on the cold, filthy concrete of the
sidewalk, in desperate need of help, what
could be the one thing that might make you
feel even the slightest bit better?
Something the very sight of would be enough
to tell you everything was going to be okay.
The flashing lights drawing closer, accompanied
by the sound of tires on the road and a wailing
siren; all signs that an ambulance is on its
way.
But what if the ambulance that came to assist
you ended up making you feel far worse than
you were before… and leaving you with injuries
unlike anything you’d ever seen?
What if it wasn’t an ambulance at all that
came to help you, what if you were found by
SCP-4419 instead?
Jeremy had been having a somewhat normal day
until his accident.
Work had been another shift of long, arduous
hours spent behind his desk.
Five o’clock finally rolled around, he grabbed
his bag and punched out.
If he’d maybe left a few minutes later,
he might have gotten away unscathed.
Instead of getting caught in the mad rush
of people leaving work, Jeremy usually took
the backstreets and avoided main roads as
a shortcut to get home.
There was less traffic, even during the rush,
and that made crossing the street safer…
usually.
He had been looking the other way when a car
came speeding down the mostly-empty side street.
The driver had slammed the breaks, but only
too late, knocking Jeremy down.
Winded, he collapsed, unable to stand as the
force of the impact had broken his leg.
The driver and a few nearby onlookers huddled
around Jeremy as he lay there with his injury.
Suddenly, the noise of an ambulance caused
the other pedestrians to mostly disperse.
Still trying to catch his breath, in the last
moments of his fading consciousness, the last
thing Jeremy remembered seeing was a pair
of figures.
They had jostled rather aggressively through
the crowd, reaching down to lift Jeremy up
and shoved him into the emergency vehicle.
They were considerably rude for medical professionals,
nobody around wanted to argue with them; most
would even go as far as to call them hostile.
But that was nothing compared to the horror
that awaited him when he reopened his eyes,
laying back on the road where he’d been
found.
His body had been rearranged, he barely recognized
it as his own.
It was like he had been turned into some grotesque
animal made using human parts.
His arms and legs had been rearranged to protrude
from his torso in an unnatural configuration.
What felt even worse was that his fingers,
toes, hands, feet… they all still worked.
All Jeremy could do was scream until he slipped
back under, a man turned into something else
entirely…
Bad days can happen to the best and worst
of us, and sometimes those bad days can spiral
into very, very bad nights.
Mike had been having a night like that.
Earlier that day, he’d lost a fair sum of
money at the races.
Gambling was one of his many vices, as was
alcohol, and to commiserate his loss, Mike
had hit the bar.
Unfortunately, his already foul mood was nudged
into full-blown temper when another patron
accidentally bumped into him.
The ensuing barfight was a complete disorientated,
drunken mess of glasses being smashed and
fists thrown.
One managed to connect hard with Mike’s
jaw, breaking it and leaving him sat on the
sidewalk in pain.
Cop cars had shown up, officers breaking up
the ruckus and paramedics arriving to treat
the more badly injured patrons.
It was then that two paramedics silently walked
up to Mike and grabbed him by both arms.
As much as he tried to pull away from their
forceful grip, his arms were covered in bruises
and cuts from the glass.
Their fingers dug in, honing in on those painful,
wounded spots so that Mike could really feel
his own injuries as they pulled him up against
his will.
Trying to verbally protest only hurt his jaw
further, meaning he could barely call for
help as he was bundled into the back of an
ambulance, doors slamming shut behind him.
The next morning introduced Mike to a whole
new and far grizzlier definition of the word
hangover.
One of the staff who worked at the bar found
him, just waiting outside when she came to
open up for business a few days later.
Sitting out the front, Mike had been left
in the gutter, although it took the barwoman
a moment to notice just what was wrong with
him… and when she saw it in full, she screamed.
Instead of Mike’s jaw being fixed, it had
been wrenched open, far wider than natural.
It was locked in a permanent, gaping expression,
the sides of his lips sporting splits that
ran all the way into his cheeks.
Lodged between both rows of Mike’s teeth,
fused to his gums was a piece of glass, too
thick for him to break to free his jaw or
even bite down on.
A mouthful of glass shards and blood, cuts
lining the inside of his cheeks, fragments
lodged in his tongue; all of that might have
been preferable, a mercy compared to what
had actually happened.
The glass was keeping his mouth stretched
out, stopping him from speaking like a transparent
gag.
And as if not being able to speak or beg for
help wasn’t bad enough, anyone that looked
through that little window was also offered
a whole other horrific view.
They could see Mike’s heart, it had been
pulled from his chest and reattached at the
back of his throat, still beating as tears
rolled down his face.
He couldn’t eat, talk, only breathing through
his nose… and it hurt.
Reg and Lee had vowed, when they first got
married, to love each other for better or
for worse, in sickness and in health, until
death did them part.
And death very nearly almost parted them.
If given the choice between dying together,
or suffering through what ended up being done
to them, not even their love for each other
would have made them want to stay alive.
The rain was beating down on the windshield
as the couple drove home in silence.
They’d had a big argument; in fact, it was
small in the grand scheme of their relationship,
just a lover’s quarrel.
In that moment, it felt like the biggest problem
in the world, as those types of squabbles
often do.
But it would’ve seemed quaint compared to
the fate that awaited both Lee and her husband
that night.
Visibility was poor, the headlights were doing
little to help Reg see through the downpour
or the dark.
He found it so hard to see, that he almost
missed their turn, quickly wrenching the steering
wheel to try and correct the mistake.
Reg lost control of the car as it slid on
the slippery road, flipping sideways and rolling
as the rain continued to pour.
The airbags deployed, the force of being thrown
around even with her seatbelt on caused Lee
to suffer a number of broken ribs.
Meanwhile, Reg’s arm was broken when the
driver’s side door connected with the ground
and dented inwards.
As the couple were left buckled in their seats,
upside down and both crying at the pain of
their injuries, they spotted the unmistakable
silhouette of an ambulance driving through
the rain towards them.
They were both so relieved that neither one
of them realized they hadn’t called the
emergency number yet.
Although the rain had long since stopped by
the time Lee woke back up, the storm was just
beginning.
Her head was spinning, everything was sore
and aching.
She had expected to be in a hospital, maybe
with Reg in the bed beside her, both of them
recovering but alive at least.
Pushing herself up by her cut, bloody hands,
Lee could feel something heavy behind her,
a weight on her back like having a rucksack
strapped to her, only it was harder to move,
almost the same mass as… a person.
Slowly looking over her shoulder, Lee screamed
when she saw the flesh of her back had been
fused to Reg’s, their skin melted and stuck
together like candlewax, each of them unable
to pull away without the pain of feeling like
they were being ripped apart.
To make matters worse, Lee had undergone…
Other modifications.
Talk about in sickness and in health…
Living alone, Rodney was relatively content
with his life.
Since retiring, he’d been able to spend
his twilight years appreciating the little
things, spending most of his time out in the
garden, tending to his flowers and occasionally
enjoying the company of his adult son.
Unfortunately, with old age comes the increased
risk of health problems, and to say Rodney
had himself more than his fair share of heart
difficulties – or a ‘bum ticker’ as
he called it – was an understatement.
While out in his garden, Rodney suffered a
violent heart attack and collapsed, wheezing
and struggling to breathe.
Luckily, his son, Keith, was in the house
at the time, he witnessed his elderly father
drop to the ground and ran out to help him,
calling for an ambulance as he tried to calm
Rodney down.
The emergency services seemed to arrive much
quicker than Keith had been expecting, a pair
of paramedics rushing through the house to
lift his dad away.
What stuck him as strange was, neither one
would tell Keith which hospital they were
talking his dad to, and they outright refused
to let him ride in the back of the ambulance
to keep Rodney lucid and reassure him that
he was in safe hands.
When Keith went to climb into the back, one
of the paramedics pushed him by his chest,
with enough strength to knock him over.
As he pulled himself up off the concrete,
the rear doors slammed shut and the ambulance
sped away to god knows where with Rodney in
the back.
After a few days of hearing nothing, Keith
had already tirelessly been calling every
hospital in the area to ask if his dad had
been admitted.
None of them had seen Rodney, and his worried
son had been just about to call the police
to file a missing persons report when his
elderly father appeared on the doorstep.
Immediately, Keith drove his dad to the emergency
room, trying to explain what had happened
with the strange ambulance.
While the hospital maintained that it wasn’t
one of theirs, they admitted Rodney and gave
him a full examination…
only to find something that would turn the
stomachs of the world’s most seasoned doctors.
Rodney had more that one heart.
Someone had given him not just a spare, but
eleven additional hearts.
They were stuffed between his natural organs
like took many books squeezed together on
a shelf.
And not one of them was beating, they were
causing far more harm than good.
Rodney’s insides were riddled with these
foreign bodies that were stopping his lungs
from fully inflating, resting on his stomach,
and wreaking havoc with his bodily functions.
Upon discovery of these extra hearts, Rodney
was rushed into the operating theatre, with
his son nervously pacing in the corridor outside.
Sadly, a doctor would soon appear to tell
Keith that the moment the surgeons removed
one of the additional hearts, Rodney’s old
bum ticker had finally given out.
Sometimes, as sad as it may be to reconcile
with, tragedy strikes.
One night, a fire broke out in a crowded bar,
leading to a whole host of people suffering
severe burns and requiring urgent medical
attention.
What they received instead was far more brutal
and barbaric.
Joyce had been in the bar when the alarms
started to ring, nobody knew what had started
it, only that they needed to evacuate.
But it didn’t take the flames long to reach
the alcohol behind the bar, and before long
the whole place was ablaze, everyone panicking
and barging past each other to get out.
Once free of the searing heat, swapping it
for the biting cold of the night air, the
commotion didn’t seem to end.
Someone near her pointed to an ambulance that
had just arrived, and a duo of paramedics
that were manhandling some of the more badly
burned bar patrons, forcing them into the
back of their vehicle.
Along with about six others, Joyce marched
up as the group protested how the injured
drinkers were being treated.
When the paramedics refused to stop, things
got uglier.
The ensuing brawl left Joyce and the other
six people with skull fractures, but rather
than just leave them behind, the paramedics
grabbed them too.
Joyce was pushed into an already overcrowded
ambulance, there were twenty-six people crammed
in there in total, including her.
Nineteen of them had nasty burns on their
skin, wounds that were only made worse by
being packed together in such a tight space
and jostled around as the ambulance drove
away.
There was no sign of the missing twenty-six
bar patrons for around a week.
The families of those that had disappeared
after the fire urged the police to keep searching
for them, with no bodies recovered on the
scene by firefighters.
Nobody had a clue where the group had gone,
Joyce’s partner, Al, even printed off missing
flyers and handed them out to anyone who would
take them.
They also happened to be the caretaker of
a local community centre, and after another
day of worrying tirelessly about Joyce, Al
moped back there to clean and lock the place
up.
What they found waiting for them was like
something out of an old horror B-movie, or
something found in the deepest parts of the
ocean.
Filling one of the rooms of the community
center was a huge, watery mass.
It wasn’t pure liquid, although Al first
mistook it for the result of a leaking pipe.
The mass was fluid, it twitched and shivered
whenever they reached out to touch it, almost
like a living thing… or what was left of
a few living things, say twenty-six bar patrons
melted down and reduced to a collective liquid
mass.
Now, you’d think having an accident out
in public would be as bad as things got, but
that’s nothing compared to being injured
in the line of duty, right in the middle of
a warzone.
That’s what happened to Private Jackson.
While he and his squad were out on a routine
patrol in Afghanistan, a group of enemy insurgents
ambushed the United States’ soldiers.
During the ensuing firefight, Private Jackson
sustained a severe gunshot wound, leaving
him bleeding out.
His comrades had called for a medical evacuation,
and were expecting a US Army helicopter to
arrive any moment.
What none of them expected was a city ambulance,
driving towards them across the battlefield
as if it was the most normal sight on Earth.
Already suspicious of the approaching vehicle,
Private Jackson’s fellow teammates raised
their weapons at the approaching paramedics.
Despite the soldiers demands for them to identify
themselves, neither one of the ambulance attendants
seemed to pay them much mind, grabbing Private
Jackson and dragging the wounded soldier towards
the vehicle.
He called to the rest of his squad, wanted
to be let go, having no idea where he was
about to be taken or why.
The commanding officer barked at the pair
of EMTs, warning if they didn’t release
Private Jackson, then his men would open fire.
Still, the paramedics didn’t seem to be
listening.
Just as they threw Jackson into their ambulance
and climbed into the cab at the front, the
other soldiers opened fire.
Squeezing their triggers, bullets were spat
from their weapons, riddling the metal sides
of vehicle as it began to drive away, siren
blaring and lights flashing.
Every shot that connected with the ambulance
seemed to cause it to leak a viscous black
fluid, like an oil, but despite this, it did
little to deter the ambulance from driving
away with Jackson captive in the back.
After being successfully extracted from the
battlefield, the remainder of the squad were
airlifted back to safety, arriving back at
their nearby base the following day.
Each one of them was solemnly silent.
All of them were confused as to how an ambulance
had appeared in the desert out of nowhere
and disappeared without a trace.
But even more so, they were concerned for
the life of their kidnapped comrade.
However, they wouldn’t have to wait long,
as arriving at their barracks revealed the
grim, grotesque fate of Private Jackson.
He was on the walls… as in, all over the
walls.
His body had been dissolved somehow, broken
down into little more than a thin, bloody
paste that had now been smeared over the interior
of the barracks.
Looking out at his former squad from the liquified
remains, was a single human eyeball, Private
Jackson’s eye, wide with horror at what
had been done to him.
SCP-4419 – known to some by the nickname
of ‘the Butcher’s Chariot’ – is still
out there.
At present, it is unknown who – or indeed
what – performs the horrific mutilations
on its victims, or even why.
It could be that SCP-4419, if it has a consciousness,
could be trying to help those it abducts,
but lacks the correct medical understanding
of how to do so.
Then again, it could be simply just being
cruel, torturing and deforming people unfortunate
enough to need emergency medical attention.
Given how sporadically this anomalous ambulance
can appear and disappear, at the site of any
medical emergency anywhere on the planet,
there’s little the Foundation can do other
than stay vigilant and pick up SCP-4419’s
‘patients’ after it has mutilated them…
or rather, they’ll can pick up whatever’s
left of its victims.
Now go and check out “SCP-2086 MAN EATING
BUS” for another anomaly that at first takes
the shape of an ordinary vehicle, but soon
becomes something far more terrifying.
And after, keep an eye out for “SCP-973
Chased by Smokey” for more horror stalking
the roads!